can it be that time of year again yes it
is budget time and indeed this time we
get the spending review as well i'm
going to tell you the things to look out
for there are three of them three
headlines here first of all we get new
economic forecasts and perhaps most
important of all though inflation is
really important this time around as
well it's gross domestic products so the
the size of the economy and you can see
just over the course of the last few
years the financial crisis there a bit
of a dip that went up up up and around
2020 early 2020 the expectation was it
was going to go even higher that dotted
line there but of course we all know
what happened next don't we look a
massive fall when covert hit lockdown's
hit and it went down there last time the
obr the office budget responsibility
looked at this it thought we're gonna
have a bit of a dip and that red line it
would go higher and higher in the next
few years but what we do know is
actually things have come in a bit
better than expected look at that white
line a bit steeper in the recovery so we
might get an upgrade on economic growth
so that's good news for us and indeed
for the chancellor also second thing
taxes we get new tax policy potentially
but there's been an awful lot happening
this year already this is showing you
the tax burden so just the total amount
of tax as a percentage of national
income in the uk and it goes all the way
over to 1955 but have a look at this we
with those national insurance increases
with corporation tax increases we've got
all of that this year massive tax
increases as a result of that the dotted
line doesn't look like it's that high
does it but actually that's now at the
highest sustained level ever so we'll
get new tax policy from the chancellor
and the question is whether it moves
that needle finally and this is unusual
we get a spending review a three-year
spending review the government's setting
out what it's spending there's been so
many numbers on this recently haven't
there so many press releases so many
announcements let's just focus on what's
actually going on here the government
spends about just over a trillion pounds
in total but you can break that down you
can break it down in two ways annually
managed expenditure and departmental
spending the blue stuff and the red
stuff the blue stuff and the management
expenditure that's the stuff the
government doesn't really control on an
annual basis stuff like debt interest
welfare pensions things like that
what we're really focused on here is the
red stuff departmental spending what is
spending on day-to-day spending and
investment in all those different
departments so let's take those two bars
and focus on them in particular look you
can see this is much higher day-to-day
spending then you've got capital that's
you know all the spending on investments
on big projects we know they're going to
go a bit higher in their spending
reviews so up to 441 113 but the
interesting thing is if we take this in
particular day-to-day spending move it
across here what we're really focusing
on here what really matters when you
pull away everything else is the extra
bit 56 billion pounds of extra spending
and we already know some of that's going
to the nhs about 14 billion pounds we
had that earlier on this year we know
some
is likely to go to schools and aid maybe
about 6 billion pounds which leaves
roughly 36 billion pounds that really is
what this spending review is about who
is going to get that money how is the
economy going to do what's going to
happen to taxes all sorts of things that
are going to be decided in this budget
and spending review it could be a very
big day